you
hello sir I have a special delivery for
you I didn't order anything if you could
just confirm your name for me so I
assure you this process will be very
speedy fantastic mr. a now if you could
please sign here here and here the
package is all yours sir
marvelous sir here is your box now
whatever you do the box must never be
opened why not
I do not know sir why I am just your
simple ordinary delivery man and the
instructions that came with the Box said
do not open ever
well do you know who sent it no I'm
afraid I do not sir
I have no idea who sent it nor what's
inside but the message clearly says do
not open I'd probably open it but I am
your ordinary very average nosy delivery
man so don't let me sway your decision
sir I mean what's the worst that can
happen
you open the box and there's nothing
inside or maybe your niche every known
plague into evil upon mankind bringing
it to the brink of destruction and
causing an eternity of suffering for
countless generations that follow me
it's probably just a pair of keys or
maybe it's filled of jewelry or better
yet chocolate I've heard humans do love
that what are you talking about anyway I
must be leaving you now sir there are
far more packages of messages to deliver
and there's a reason I've won best
delivery man 2460 seven times in a row
but before I go I believe I was supposed
to warn you about a cat named curiosity
history repeating itself and some kind
of panda I don't really remember but
hopefully that helps you sir I wish you
the best of luck sir hopefully your fate
is not as bad as the last one what was
that
I said have a wonderful day because it
may be your last so would you open the
box if the choice was yours Pandora's
box is a video that I covered quite a
while back when the channel was still
fairly new and it's one of those videos
that I wasn't entirely happy with
because I missed some talking points and
I definitely could have made it more
interesting which is why we're covering
it again today at this point I'd like to
think that most of us are at least
familiar with the name Pandora and the
first human woman who opened the said
box and cursed humanity forever sounds
dramatic I know and that's because it is
and I'd expect nothing else from Greek
mythology if I'm being honest for those
unfamiliar of the story there's no need
to worry because we will recap it once
more before discussing it any further
now before the YouTube historical and
mythological Nobel prize-winning experts
come out of the woodwork to tell me it
was now tables you buffoon it was a pit
house jar you stupid man that is true
Pandora's box did start off as a job a
piss jar to be precise but over the
years due to the many different versions
of the story somewhere along the line it
got lost in translation and became a box
which in a more modern context is
certainly more alluring than a jar no
get it a lie I want to know what was in
the jar no one cares what was in the jar
because boxes are just better end of
discussion
anyway the story begins with pretty much
everybody's favorite god Zeus and the
two Titan brothers Prometheus and
Epimetheus Prometheus who created man
and Epimetheus who created the animals
and gave them all of their positive
traits but when it was man's turn
Epimetheus had run out of traits to give
Zeus not being the biggest fan of
Prometheus creation was intrigued to see
how mankind
survive or more so excited at the
prospect of their inevitable demise
Prometheus however was not ready to
watch his creations suffer and so he
stole fire from Olympus and gave it to
man who would use it to thrive to Zeus
this was not only cheating but a
challenge and so rather than simply just
taking fire away he hatched an elaborate
plan of revenge against Prometheus and
his creation
similar to how Prometheus created man
from clay Zeus would order Hephaestus to
mold Pandora the first woman to really
bring Pandora to life and to build
somewhat of a personality each of the
gods and goddesses bestowed a gift upon
her from Athena she was given the gift
of craftsmanship needlework and weaving
from Aphrodite she was given beauty and
the ability to feel a range of emotion
and from her me she was given craftiness
and guile and he would also named her
Pandora it then fell to Zeus to give her
her final two gifts curiosity and a
mysterious box that she was told never
to open and once she was ready Zeus
would send for Hermes to deliver Pandora
to Epimetheus as his bride-to-be
despite Prometheus warning his brother
to never accept a gift from Zeus
Epimetheus ignored his brother and
married Pandora anyway what then follow
the marriage is what we can only assume
as a period of calm as Zeus is plan of
revenge was long-term as each day passed
Pandora grew more and more curious as to
what was inside the box until where she
could wait no longer and on that very
day she gave in to the curiosity that
Zeus had given her and opened the box
inside of the box Zeus had placed every
known evil and Pandora had just
unleashed greed suffering illness and
hardship upon humanity
Prometheus creation of man would be
brought to the brink of destruction
Pandora who felt an immense a guilt for
what she had done
opened the box one last time in the hope
that there was something good inside and
there was one last thing inside hope it
was this hope they gave humanity the
strength to endure their hardships and
continue surviving now there are some
elements to this story that I noticed in
the previous video that some people
missed or failed to understand I think
the most common being Zeus is intent and
the comment I saw very often was along
the lines of why woods us give Pandora a
box that she was never allowed to open
why would he give her curiosity and then
a mysterious box
Zeus may have told Pandora to never
opened the box but make no mistake he
always intended and planned for the Box
to be opened if you tell a child or even
an adult in most cases not to do
something without then explaining why
they shouldn't most of the time they
will give in to their curiosity and they
will do that very thing you told them
not to when Prometheus stole the fire
from Olympus
Zeus could have easily destroyed him and
his creation right there and then
instead Zeus wanted some kind of revenge
the kind of revenge that he found
amusing the kind that was filled of
irony and so he played the long game he
had something created which in this case
was a woman the counterpart to
Prometheus his creation and it would be
this creation that he intended to
destroy mankind or at least caused a
great amount of suffering so to answer
the question why would soos give Pandora
a box and tell her not to open it
because I guess he felt like it would be
a fun way to watch humanity suffer and
to teach Prometheus a lesson even though
he would be punished again later the
next question I wanted to answer was why
would Zeus place hope in the box if he
just wanted to destroy humanity anyway
this hope can be seen as a good thing
but it's much more likely that it was
intended as false hope and the constant
belief that despite all this suffering
one day things will get better when in
reality he never intended them to you
can also argue that Zeus never wanted to
entirely destroy humanity and so hope
was him being merciful and there are
several poets who interpret the story in
this way but given the fact that
everything inside the box was evil and
the box itself was meant for revenge it
certainly feels like Zeus had the last
laugh the story of Pandora's Box has
been covered by almost every poet of a
note throughout the years the organist
of Megara and the author Babri Estelle
of a rather different story
whether jar was filled of blessings as
opposed to evil this jar however would
not be opened by Pandora instead it was
an unnamed man who would open the jar
out of curiosity releasing all of the
blessings which would then be lost to
humanity this version of the story also
heavily influenced the Aesop's fables
where Zeus is described as gathering all
of the good things and placing them in a
jar when humanity then opened the jar
all of the good things flew back up to
the heavens and only one thing remained
hope promising that one day it will
bestow upon us everything that had been
lost one of the reasons that a sub gives
in terms of why bad things happen to us
is because they are all around us
whereas the good things must descend
from heaven and that is why they are
much more rare as well as an unnamed man
it was also believed the jar may have
been opened by Pandora's husband so
there are several versions of the story
where the blame isn't placed on Pandora
some of you may have also noticed the
similarities with the biblical story of
Adam and Eve the individuals involved
may differ but there is the recurring
theme of curiosity being humanity's
downfall as well as the inability to
follow a basic command without it being
explained hopefully this video has been
a more comprehensive breakdown of the
story than the previous video and
hopefully any unanswered and lingering
questions now have been answered if they
still haven't or you just like to share
your thoughts with me then please do so
in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained stop calling it a
box you stupid man stop calling it a box
you stupid man stop calling it a box you
stupid buffoon
[Music]